il était traqué par toutes les polices
d'europe makaveli linden 20 ans est
soupçonné d'avoir commis un meurtre le
15 octobre dernier en norvège
c'est dans cet appartement d'un quartier
huppé d'oslo qu'ils auraient pénétré par
effraction tard dans la nuit pour
commettre un cambriolage surpris par le
propriétaire des lieux un orthézien qui
a fait fortune dans la vente de bitcoin
une monnaie virtuelle d'internet
il lui assène alors une quinzaine de
coups de couteau avant de prendre la
fuite
le suspect connu des services de police
traverse d'abord la suède puis
l'allemagne et la suisse avant de
rejoindre la france où il est arrêté
ce que l'on sait ça qu'a priori il a eu
une enfance un peu compliqué puisqu'il
dit qu'il prenait des stupéfiants depuis
l'âge de 14 ans et
il semble un peu désoeuvrés ils semblent
un peu renfermé sur lui-même sa cavale
et stopper ce mardi à 16h30 en gare de
dijon alors qu'il est à bord d'un ter en
provenance de châlons en champagne
repéré par les policiers de la berri il
est alors interpellé puis conduit au
commissariat central
la cour d'appel l'a placé sous écrou
extraditionnel donc la norvège à 40
jours pour nous adresser les pièces du
dossier demandé l'extradition et dans 40
jours on pourra envisager de statuer sur
l'extradition est demandée par la
norvège une extradition possible
seulement si la suède son pays d'origine
l'autorisent en attendant makaveli
linden est incarcéré à la maison d'arrêt
de dijon
il encourt une peine de 21 ans de prison